skip bayless debating that maggie  gyllenhaal shouldn't have been in batman  that was that was a segment on first  date like yeah she wasn't enrolled like  that you need a halle berry oh like they  were basically saying she wasn't  attractive enough  the dark knight the new batman overrated  or underrated skip the dark knight is a  good movie but not a great one  i didn't like it that number one batman  had only the third largest role in this  movie i thought jack nicholson played a  better joker than heath ledger oh my god  god god bless you pleasure but i just  did and finally i must say that maggie  gyllenhaal was weak as the love interest  because i didn't buy her at all  i would agree with you there i wasn't  feeling hot at all a roll like that you  need to get a hallelberry beyonce  somebody how about it's a 9 lakh than a  gabrielle union somebody like even a  sister just throw them up and somebody  fine she wasn't it you got me there